"ANGLE".
OH, THE DEMOCRATS NEVER TRUMP IF
A NATIONALICS GOING OFF THE
RAILS, MY FRIENDS.
EARLIER THIS WEEK, WE EXPOSED
THEIR TRUE MOTIVES DURING THE
PARTIAL GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN.
THEY WANT TO KEEP IT GOING AS
LONG AS POSSIBLE FOR PURE MITT
CAL GAIN, SIMPLE AS THAT.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THE
GOVERNMENT WORKERS BE DAMNED,
TRYING TO EMBARRASS THE
PRESIDENT.
SO MUCH FOR GOVERNING.
IT'S PATHETIC.
NOW, TONIGHT, WE TAKE IT A STEP
FURTHER.
TONIGHT WE'LL SYSTEMATICALLY
EXPOSE THE TACTICS AND METHODS
OF THE DEMOCRATS AND MEDIA
COLLABORATORS USE TO ADVANCE
THEIR EXTREME VAEN.
AGENDA.
I CALL THIS EDITION THE CRUEL
HOAX.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS HURLED
COORS INSULTS AT EVERYBODY FROM
SENATORS TO STORMY DANIELS.
HE'S SEPARATED IMMIGRANT
CHILDREN FROM THEIR PARNS AT THE
BORDER.
THE PATTERN HERE CRUELTY.
>> I THINK WHAT TRUMP PRACTICES
IS CRUELTY.
HE'S PART OF HIS BRAND IS
CRUELTY.
>> THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
ADOPTED A CONSCIOUS POLICY OF
CRUELTY.
>> THIS IS WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
WANTS, USING CRUELTY AS HIS
MESSAGE.
>> Laura: I'M SORRY, IT'S SO
PREPOSTEROUS AND OBVIOUS.
THEY WRITE ENTIRE ARTICLES,
DEVOTE ENTIRE SEGMENTS TO MAKING
THEIR CRUELTY CASE.
NO NEED TO DEBATE ACTUAL ISSUES
OR PROPOSE ACTUAL SOLUTIONS.
JUST CALL SOME ONE A NAME, LIKE
RACIST, SEXIST, MYSOGYNIST, OR
CRUEL.
CHECK OUT THESE LUDICROUS
HEADLINES.
NO MATTER WHAT, REMEMBER, IF
TRUMP IS INVOLVED IT MUST BE A
CRUEL OUTCOME.
LIKE ANY ISSUE REGARDING TRANLS
GENDERISM.
ON BUDGET PRIORITIES.
AND ONE OF MY PERSONAL
FAVORITES, THE KNEE-SLAPPER
ARGUMENT MADE BY FORMER BUSCHIE
MICHAEL GERCHEN, NOT JUST THAT
TRUMP IS CRUEL IT'S ALSO THAT HE
ENCOURAGES OTHER LEADERS AROUND
THE WORLD TO BE CRUEL, TOO.
AND OF COURSE, ANYTHING RELATED
TO IMMIGRATION, SHORT OF A WAVE
THEM ALL IN POLICY, IS ALWAYS
GOING TO BE CRUEL.
WELL, YOU GET THE POINT.
LIBERALS AND NEVER-TRUMPERS WANT
YOU TO BELIEVE THAT THEY HAVE
THE MONOPOLY ON COMPASSION.
IF YOU DON'T BELIEVE IN THEIR
SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC AND FOREIGN
POLICY AGENDA, YOU'RE NOT JUST
WRONG, YOU'RE CRUEL.
AND TRUMP IS THE CRUELLEST OF
ALL.
>> IT MIGHT COME DOWN TO THE
FACT THAT HE COULD WELL BE JUST
AN EMPTY MAN, AN EMPTY HUMAN
BEING, WITH NO SOUL.
>> Laura: STILL TRYING TO GET
OVER MICHAEL STEELE'S RED
SWEATER SITUATION.
THAT'S CRUEL.
NOW, MY FRIEND, THE BUDDHA SAID,
PARAPHRASING, THAT THE FINGER IS
ALWAYS POINTED BACK AT YOU.
WATCH WHAT YOU'RE DOING WITH THE
CRUEL LANGUAGE.
JUST LOOK AT THE CURRENT BORDER
STANDOFF ISSUE, APARENT, THAT
THE DEMOCRATS AND THE
NEVER-TRUMPERS ARE ACTUALLY THE
CRUELLEST OF THEM ALL.
WHILE THEY SPENT HOS ON THE
BORDER BEMOANING THE PLIGHT OF
MIGRANT FAMILIES, THEY TREAT
AMERICAN VICTIMS OF ILLEGAL
ALIEN CRIMES WITH COMPLETE
INDIFFERENCE.
EVEN SCORN.
AFTER THE PRESIDENT SAID THIS IN
HIS OVAL OFFICE ADDRESS.
>> President Trump: OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS I'VE MET WITH
DOZENS OF FAMILIES, WHOSE LOVED
ONES WERE STOLEN BY ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
I WILL NEVER FORGET THE PAIN IN
THEIR EYES, THE TREMBLE IN THEIR
VOICES, AND THE SADNESS GRIPPING
THEIR SOULS.
HOW MUCH MORE AMERICAN BLOOD
MUST WE SHED BEFORE CONGRESS
DOES ITS JOB?
>> Laura: UNFUNNY, NBC'S LATE
NIGHT HOST SETH MEYERS RESPONDED
ON TWITTER.
IS THIS OVAL OFFICE SVU?
GOSH, HILARIOUS, MOCKING THE
PLIGHT OF VICTIMS.
AS IF THEY'RE COLLATERAL DAMAGE
IN THE BATTLE FOR OPEN BORDERS.
AND FOR DEMOCRATS LIKE PELOSI
AND OTHERS, ALWAYS SOMETHING
LIKE, SURE, ANY LIFE LOST IS
TRAGIC, BUT --
>> BEING CONCERNED ABOUT EVERY
DEATH THAT HAPPENS, BECAUSE
OF -- BECAUSE YOU LIVE IN AN
IMPERFECT WORLD, THAT'S VERY
SAD.
>> TERRIBLE STORIES, AND WE
DON'T WANT TO MINIMIZE THE PAIN
OF ANY VICTIMS, ANY FAMILIES,
THAT ANYONE IS FEELING, RIGHT?
IT'S AWFUL, THESE TRAGEDIES.
SHOULDN'T HAPPEN.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP BACKING UP
HIS DIRE WARNINGS WITH GRISLY
STORIES OF CRIMES BLAMED ON
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS.
>> Laura: OKAY, THAT COULD BE MY
FAVORITE NEW GRAPHIC.
THERE IS NO "BUT", THESE ARE
AMERICANS WHO WOULD BE ALIVE
TODAY IF POLITICIANS DID THEIR
JOBS AND DID EVERYTHING THAT WAS
NECESSARY TO PROTECT AMERICA'S
BORDERS.
NOW, WE'RE CONSTANTLY LECTURED
ABOUT BEING SENSITIVE TO VICTIMS
AND HEARING THEM OUT.
THAT'S FAIR.
AND WE ALL SAY A LOT, ESPECIALLY
ON TV, SOMETIMES YOU OVERSTEP, I
GET IT.
NO ONE IS PERFECT.
BUT THEY HAVE TO HAVE
SENSITIVITY HERE FOR THE VICTIMS
OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT CRIME.
ARE THEY TO BE IGNORED JUST
BECAUSE THEY DON'T FIT A
PARTICULAR IDEOLOGY?
AND CONSERVATIVES SHOULDN'T DO
THIS ON ONE ANOTHER, LIBERALS
SHOULDN'T DO IT HERE.
WHEN SOME ONE DOES TRY TO
MENTION THE SUFFERING OF ILLEGAL
ALIEN CRIME VICTIMS, SADLY,
THEY'RE TREATED THIS WAY.
>> EVEN IF I WERE TO GRANT YOU
THAT, OKAY, THE POINT IS THE
ILLEGAL ALIEN CRIME RATE SHOULD
BE ZERO.
IT SHOULD BE, YOU CAN DO YOUR
NAILS, YOU DOUGH WHO CAN'T DO
THEIR NAILS?
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN KILLED,
ANA, BY DANGEROUS KNOWN ILLEGAL
ALIENS WHO HAVE BEEN ALLOWED TO
STAY IN THE COUNTRY BECAUSE OF
THE LEFTIST POLICIES OF PEOPLE
LIKE YOU PROMOTE, SO-CALLED
SANCTUARY CITIES.
>> I'M SO TIRED OF THIS.
>> Laura: RAISE YOUR HAND IF YOU
THINK ANA NAVARRO DOES HER OWN
NAILS.
REPUBLICAN IMPOSTERS LIKE
NAVARRO ARE CRUELLY INDIFFERENT.
THAT'S A COOL STUNT.
CALLOUSNESS EXTENDS TO AMERICANS
WHO PAY ABOUT $150 BILLION TAB
THAT ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION COSTS
TO US, BUT ALSO THE INDIFFERENCE
IN LEGAL IMMIGRANTS WHO HAVE
BEEN RAPED, ABUSED, TRAFFICKED,
RUN OVER, AND MURDERED SADLY BY
CERTAIN VICIOUS ILLEGAL ALIENS.
WHEN CALIFORNIA OFFICER SINGH
WAS WLAD TO REST AFTER BEING
KILLED BY AN ILLEGAL DURING A
ROUTINE TRAFFIC STOP, CALIFORNIA
GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM ATTENDED
AN NBA GAME.
SENATOR KAMALA HARRIS DID OFFER
HER RESPECTS TO THE RAPPER
COMMON.
SOMEHOW SHE FOUND THE TIME TO
HANG OUT THERE.
NO ATEMPTING THE FUNERAL OF AN
OUTSTANDING CONSTITUENT.
AND THESE ARE THE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE THE NERVE TO CALL DONALD
TRUMP CRUEL?
IF IT'S NOT A DEATH THAT THEY
CAN EXPLOIT FOR POLITICAL GAIN,
THEY'RE JUST NOT INTERESTED IN
IT AT ALL.
MEANWHILE, TRUMP IS TRULY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE CHILDREN ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE BORDER.
AND THE ONLY WAY TO PROTECT THEM
IS TO DEINCENTIVIZE THE
DANGEROUS TRIP NORTHWARD AND
BUILD A WALL TO REINFORCE AN